تثقيف شراء النفط الروسيه عند السعر
الستين دولارا يدخل حيز التنفيذ
القرار الذي يهدف الى حرمان روسيا من
مواردها الماليه اتفقت عليها الدول
الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه
السبعه واستراليا
له ثلاثه اهداف اولا تعزيز عقوباتنا
وثانيا
لانه سيسمح بتناول بعض النفط الروسي
المنقول البحرا ونقله من قبل الوسطاء
الاتحاد الاوروبي الى دول الثالثه
اماروسيا فصنعت الى تاكيد انها لن تصدر
الخامه الخاضعه لسقف سحريه فارضه الغرب
حتى لو اضطرت لخفض الانتاج
قرار الغرب التدخل سافر ينافق واعد
التجاره الحره ومن شانه زعزعه استقرار
اسواق الطاقه العالميه من خلال احداث شحن
في المعروض هو بينما تترقبوا اسواق النفط
العالميه تداعيات قرار وضع سقف سعري للنفط
الروسيه قررت دول تحالف اوبك بلاس الابقاء
على حصص انتاجها في ظل اجواء من انعدام
اليقين مع دخول العقوبات الجديده التي
تستهدف النفط الروسيه حيث التنفيذ